in March of 1941 Marvel Comics
predecessor company timely comics
introduced an intentionally patriotic
superhero whose goal would be to rile up
support by the American people for
American involvement during World War
two by having the superhero constantly
defeat a caricature of Adolf Hitler
while the characters popularity began to
wane at the end of World War two
his popularity grew more so than ever
before after his reintroduction into
Marvel Comics in the 1960s and his
placement as the leader of the superhero
team the Avengers what's going on guys
this is Rob and today we're going to be
talking about Captain America
so for the sake of this video we're
going to be discussing the popularity of
Captain America because one of the most
common questions that I hear with people
is why is Captain America so popular why
is he so well-known among those inside
Marvel Comics and those outside of
Marvel Comics because he's really kind
of a mainstay and there's some debate
here as to whether or not he's the most
popular character in Marvel Comics I
think that as of 2007 or something like
that aids sold somewhere around 200
million issues and some people look at
spider-man and say he's more popular
some people look at Thor and say the
Thor is more popular but we're going to
talk about about Captain America's
popularity here when it comes to Captain
America you have to look at what he
represents in order to understand his
popularity and Captain America is not
just any Marvel comic book character I
mean there's there's thousands and
hundreds of thousands and possibly even
millions of coming book characters if
you take into account the one shots that
you saw in the early days of timely
comics characters that were rolled back
into Marvel Comics after timely comics
became Marvel Comics there are a lot of
characters out there and Captain America
really kind of stands alone in the realm
of individuals in Marvel Comics in
Captain America represents the best of
the United States the best that we could
we could strive for he stands for
righteousness for fairness for making
the right call doing the right thing you
know he never makes a promise that he
can't keep he never breaks his promises
you know he's always fair he's always
right he's a gentleman to women that he
comes across you know he's a gentleman
to men that he comes across you know
he's the epitome of what we perceived to
be the absolute best of us as the
American people and in the 1940s you
know American patriotism was really a
big thing I mean you had the Axis powers
you had World War two going on and Adolf
Hitler and the Axis powers represented
the antithesis to what America
represented at the time we represented
truth justice the American Way you know
to kind of steal a phrase from from
Superman and with the Axis powers it was
the opposite of that with the Axis
powers
it was oppression it was fascism it was
as you can live but only under the
conditions that we set it wasn't freedom
and so Captain America represented the
American righteousness the American
might fighting against the oppression of
fascism on a cartoonist level and so it
was really kind of a way for propaganda
to reach children to reach multiple
facets of humanity because remember bait
you know in the United States at the
time common I'm sorry Captain America
was not really just a comic book
character Captain America appeared in
newspapers and he appeared in magazines
he appeared all over the place he had
his own serial so he was huge in the
1940s but because of the fact you know
towards the end of World War two that
patriotism was kind of going away or the
need for for heightened patriotism so to
speak was going away his popularity kind
of went away with it because there
really wasn't a need for someone like
Captain America who really kind of had
this extreme you know patriotism going
on now in the 1960s with his reimagines
America was in a sort of state of chaos
when it came to our social atmosphere we
had the civil rights movement the Cold
War hippies in the Vietnam War there
were a lot of things going on and the
American people really kind of wanted
something to rally around not the
American people as a whole but those who
were a fan of comics those who are
looking for something to to verify that
they as people were good that we as
Americans weren't wrong that we make
mistakes we stumble we fall but in the
end were still inherently good people
and Captain America was that that was
what Captain America did initially with
his reintroduction he was in I think it
was tales of suspense number one 110 but
I'm not going to swear to that but he
was kind of brought back in a one-issue
with Johnny Storm of the Fantastic Four
and at the end of the comic it turned
out that it wasn't actually Captain
America it was a villain named Acrobat
he was kind of a member of a trapeze
group I think it was and you know you'd
have been involved in some crimes and so
on and so forth but nonetheless at the
end of the comics Marvel was really kind
of dipping their toe in the water and
they were asking the question how
receptive would it be would Captain
America be if we brought him that
that he wasn't extremely well-received
by comic book here I'm sorry by Bart
Marvel comics fans because Marvel Comics
fans looked at Captain America much the
same way that people looked at Captain
America in the 1940s people needed a
sign of patriotism people needed to sign
that you know we need someone that we
can look at that can be the kind of icon
of America the kind of icon of what we
can stand for and people wanted that to
be it wanted to have something to rally
around they wanted that as something
they could rally with they could kind of
grab hold of and rip and run you know
with a sort of banner so to speak and so
from the 1960s onward Captain America
really stayed as this mainstay and the
Marvel Comics universe because as Marvel
Comics progressed they became more dark
Marvel Comics became much darker they
became more sinister there were far CT
er things going on and there had to be
one ray of light among everything that
went on in the Marvel Comics and that
was Captain America when the Avengers
were in a state of turmoil when you had
the Civil War series going on there had
to be the one guy who was fighting for
the right cause there had to be someone
somewhere who was doing the right thing
and that was Captain America no matter
what happened in the Marvel Comics no
matter how bad things got Captain
America was always there fighting the
good fight he was always leading the
group of the good guys and that's why he
was so popular because at the end of the
day he never compromises morals he
always fought the good fight and if
there was no one else that color book
fans could rely on to be the sole voice
of righteousness and freedom and liberty
in Marvel Comics it was Captain America
that they could rely on so with that
being said I want to go and bring this
video to an end hope you guys enjoyed it
if you did let me know and I will catch
you guys later peace